qui a déjà entendu qu'elles ou ils
avaient du potentiel que ce soit par vos
parents vous professeur ans je suis
complètement bio je vois rien j'espère
qu'à des mains qui se lèvent et qui a
déjà entendu ou 4 s'est déjà dit qu'il
ou elle ne devait pas gâcher ce
potentiel
l'étrange quelque part ce mélange de
fierté et de pression de peur peur de ne
pas être à la hauteur
peur de gaspiller son talent cette peur
me pousse souvent à faire de choix dans
lesquels on ne s'engage pas vraiment
pour surtout ne pas se fermer portes en
tout cas ce fut mon cas
bonne élève au lycée on encourage à
faire prépa pour ne pas me fermer portes
après la prépa je choisi l'école la
mieux classée pour le pam fermer de
portes après deux ans d'école je dois
faire un stage je sais pas trop quoi
prendre alors je fais du conseil pour ne
pas me fermer portes
bref jusqu'à la remise des diplômes on
peut dire que tout allait comme sur des
roulettes ou plutôt comme sur des rails
et je m'apprêtais à dérailler sacrant
pourquoi cette sortie de route pourquoi
pas une carrière classique parce que je
pense que l'écart qui nous sont
habituellement présentes dans lesquelles
ne sont pas nécessairement celles qui
répondent plus à notre besoin sens mais
revenons rat est revenu au conseil
peut-être que certains parmi vous ont
déjà envisagé un passage voire une
carrière dans le conseil il ya de très
bonnes raisons à cela
le métier de consultant et
intellectuellement stimulant chaque
mission est un nouveau défi ni un
nouveau problème à résoudre une
entreprise ou un secteur à découvrir
il est reconnu socialement vous
demandera jamais pourquoi vous êtes
devenu consultant comme si ça coulait de
source
et même si vos interlocuteurs aurait des
difficultés à définir ce que vous faites
exactement ils ne respectent enfin il et
pécuniairement intéressant une
gratification mensuelle de stagiaires
avoisiner les 1750 euros alors que je
faisais pas partie des plus grands
cabinets
autant de raisons entre autres tu peux
m'expliquer l'attractivité de ce métier
et qui me faisait oublier que bien loin
de changer le monde
les dettes grandes entreprises à devenir
encore plus grosse à gagner encore plus
d'argent c'est carrière ressemble pour
moi un engrenage
un jeu auquel on jurerait bien plus
longtemps qu'on le voudrait parce que on
passe un niveau chaque année et cette
perspective d'évolution nous pousse à
rester pour décrocher tel bonus
atteindre tel niveau est maintenu dans
cette évolution
nous n'avons pas toujours le temps de
l'an viii de faire le point de chercher
à savoir ce qu'on réalise si on se
réalise et un jour propulseur du métro à
la défense par une marée de costumes
sombres qui c'est parti sur le parvis
sur gym question qu'est-ce que je hais
cette question j'ai pas été la seule à
m'imposer
lors de mon stage en conseil j'étais
encadré par un senior un diplômé de
centrale supélec le consultant parfait
toujours impeccable très à l'aise en
présentation confiant sûr de lui il
avait compris combien la forme influe
sur la perception qu'on a du fond et il
était extrêmement entier je me souviens
une reprise de présentation où ils
traquent y ait le moindre douglas passe
la marche de 5 mm plus grande sur ce
live
un an après mon stage je reçois un
message sur linkedin de sa part du
m'attendais à ce qu'il m'annonce qu'il
était devenu manager pas vraiment il
venait de quitter le cabinet il
remettait tout en question ses choix sa
carrière tracé il se demandait ce qu'il
voulait vraiment et je sais pas vous
mais moi j'ai pas voulu trop patent pour
poser cette question
quand je reçois ce message je travaille
dans un secteur dont j'espérais qu'il
correspondrait mieux à mes attentes
la santé j'ai travaillé un an et demi en
alternance dans un groupe de cliniques
dans le cadre d'un master de
polytechnique sur la gestion de projets
innovants
j'espérais mettre l'innovation au
service des patients améliorer la prise
en charge plus difficile parcours de
soin mais projet se révélèrent
pour continuer à mettre notamment parce
que je travaille au siège à paris loin
des cliniques où se trouvaient les
médecins les patients
cette distance créer une déconnexion je
croyais avoir trouvé une ovation génial
et quand je la présente le médecin me
rétorquer qu'ils n'en avaient pas besoin
c'était extrêmement frustrant j'avais
l'impression déployé des trésors
d'énergie pour que la montagne accouche
d'une souris
j'ai appris beaucoup et notamment que le
changement ne s'impose pas si vous
voulez changer ce qui se passe faut
aller là où ça se passe grâce à ces
expériences j'ai pu définir ce que je
voulais un engagement de terrain chine
ait du sens pour moi c'est vague
ça peut signifier une foule de choses et
j'en suis bien consciente alors que je
parcours le forum carrières des
chaussées de cv plein les bras et tour
10 par les multiples possibilités
qu'offre une dizaine de stands est
toujours en arrière fond cette espèce de
pression de poire de gâcher son
potentiel
parmi les stands je découvre le choix de
l'école l'association vient d'être créée
et ça plaît à leur titre phare france
elle veut promouvoir l'égalité des
chances je me souviens encore du message
qui était affiché un jour la réussite
d'un enfant ne dépendra plus de son
origine sociale
ça me parle ça me parle parce que je ne
peux que constater et déplorer la
reproduction des inégalités dans notre
système scolaire et en même temps je
continue de croire que l'éducation peut
changer la société
je continue de croire que l'école doit
permettre de s'élever donc tous les sens
du terme
le programme propose diplômés de grandes
écoles de s'investir dans l'éducation en
s'engageant enseigné deux ans dans des
collèges rép
ce qu'on appelait auparavant les zep et
ça aussi sympa ça me parle parce que je
crois qu à force d'avancer sur le rail
nous créons notre bulle nous parlons à
des personnes qui ne sont vos balles
mansigné
som réalisé que notre coeur du monde
incomplète plusieurs points notre
société vivent en parallèle est par
définition ne se croisent jamais et je
crois que cette ignorance l'indifférence
qu'elles génèrent sont vraiment délétère
j'ai donc fait le choix d'être prof pour
deux ans d'abord pour voir pour essayer
pour comprendre et c'est une expérience
fabuleuse
elle colle ont besoin de sens ce n'est
pas seulement parce que cing agit dans
une fois qu'il ya du sens ça ne veut pas
dire renoncer à y chercher ce qui vous
plaisait ailleurs je parlais de
stimulation intellectuelle être profonde
la new team qu'on pourrait imaginer
c'est faire face à des situations sans
cesse différentes parfois déroutante
sait s'adapter à ce groupe vivant qu'est
une classe c'est accepter que ce qui a
fonctionné hier ne marchera peut-être
pas aujourd'hui et chaque cours est un
défi celui de trouver de créer parmi les
mille manières d'enseigner celle qui
correspond le mieux à votre objectif est
à la situation présente
c'est une immense liberté dans la
manière d'enseigner mais aussi dans le
contenu dans ce que vous voulez
transmettre c'est l'occasion de coopérer
de rendre vivante cette
transdisciplinarité d'en parler c'est
j'ai un exemple par exemple que j'ai
fait une séquence sur les récits
héroïques donc y aller
2000 yade au seigneur des anneaux
j'ai travaillé notamment avec ma
collègue d'arts plastiques et c'était
génial de voir les élèves donner vie par
l'écriture au héros qu'ils avaient créée
par le dessin être prof c'est enseigner
mais c'est surtout apprendre chaque
séance est une expérimentation
l'occasion d'améliorer son contenu ses
méthodes et surtout sa posture ma plus
grande joie ne vient cependant pas de ma
propre révolution mais de celle des
élèves de la persévérance que je peux
voir dans celui qui auparavant s'arrêter
à la première difficulté de l' envie de
réussir qui saisissent celle qui croyait
que ça ne valait même pas la peine
d'essayer
je me souviens de mehdi un petit
bonhomme ultra provoqua tard avec un
monde en ont besoin d'attention et la
fâcheuse habitude de se faire
constamment exclure de cours de maths il
avait toujours la flemme d'écrire dès
qu'ils devaient écrire quelque chose ou
gribouillait les premiers mots et quand
je détourner le regard fermé son cahier
comme s'il avait un petit à petit nous
avancions il y avait des jours
difficiles où il arrivait balancer son
sac sur la table safari data centre
d'hébron et ne voulait rien faire mais
nous avons su et lors de la rédaction
finale de cette fameuse séquence sur les
héros rédaction finale qui s'arrangeait
en général pour ces faits je le vois
écrire écrire sans discontinuer et quand
il a fini le temps sa copie une page et
demie où transparaît toute sa joie qui
sont plaisir d'inventer de raconter des
histoires j'étais super fier mais
surtout heureuse de voir sa fierté son
étonnement presque
quelques mois plus tôt il n'en serait
jamais cru capable
benjamin sanders dans la vidéo disait
que les bons leaders ont toujours
confiance dans la capacité de leur
public ou des gens qui veulent qu'on
fasse je prétends pas du tout être
nouveau leader mais je pense que cette
idée de confiance c'était la première
chose à transmettre en tant
qu'enseignante ce sont là mes plus beaux
souvenirs que soient les deux bonnes
raisons pour être prof quand mon père a
à peu près à accepter ma décision
si une devinette qu'il m'a envoyé donc
les deux bonnes raisons pour être prof
juillet août
derrière cette tentative d'humour il y
avait une vraie peur celle que je
m'ennuie aucun risque
les journées d'enseignement sont
intenses je connaissais la fatigue pour
ressent après une journée passée à
bosser sur une jenny jones ne quittant
excellent d yeux que pour avaler en
vitesse le dîner que l'équipe s'est fait
livrer et tout en sachant que le
lendemain matin on devra aller présenter
les résultats trop tôt aux clients mais
j'ignorais que je serai tout aussi
décidés à
une journée de quoi ou inattention tous
les instants est nécessaire pour garder
en tête votre objectif la manière dont
vous voulez amener les élèves à
l'apprentissage
souton intégrant ce qu'il peut y avoir
des imprévus de vivant tout en étant
pleinement présente à ce qui se passe
pour chacun d'entre eux je parle
d'intensité je parle de fatigue
j'insiste s'engager dans une voie qui a
du sens
ça ne signifie pas embrasser un
sacerdoce se sacrifier pour la cause
je n'ai pas eu à me rappeler constamment
pourquoi j'avais fait ce choix quand je
sors du rer et non plus du métro entre
des tours qui ne sont plus seuls de la
défense mais d'une cité au petit matin
je ne répète pas comme un mantra un jour
la réussite d'un film de pondre est plus
homogène sociale ou non je suis
tranquille car cohérente
je ne me sens plus tourmenté mais légère
je ne manque plus que je fous là où à
quoi je sers
peut-être que vous avez l'impression que
ça sonne comme une évidence aujourd'hui
mais c'est parce que j'ai un an de recul
et de beaux souvenirs plein la tête
ce ne fut pas un choix facile j'avais
peur j'avais peur de gâcher mon
potentiel j'avais peur de ne pas être à
la hauteur des attentes qu'on avait pour
moi que j'avais pour moi et c'est normal
d'avoir c'est normal d'avoir peur qu'on
se décide enfin quand on prend une porte
et qu'on redoute qu'elles se referment
derrière nous la proposition du choix de
l'école étaient rassurantes deux ans
d'engagement et en accompagnement après
pour réintégrer le monde normal
sans ça je n'aurais sûrement jamais osé
me lancer sans le choix de l'école je
n'aurais jamais été prof je veux dire je
n'avais jamais songé à devenir
enseignant
j'ai toujours été sensible aux
inégalités particulièrement aux
inégalités scolaires mais ça me faisait
juste la partie mon horizon
ça n'était pas une vocation si vous avez
un projet un rêve
pourquoi le repousser à plus tard faites
attention à cette logique qui voudrait
qu'en sortant d'école
on sécurise un salaire on sécurise un
prestige on devient rapidement
prisonniers de cette sécurité
j'entendais et j'entends encore beaucoup
de mes camarades d'hier alors je vais
faire x années dans le conseil ou la
finance
je mets de l'argent de côté je construis
mon cv et après je me consacre à tel
projet qui nous tient à coeur
pourquoi attendre a fortiori s'il
n'avait pas d'emprunt à rembourser il ya
un vrai risque est ce qu'une fois
manager ou associés vous trouverez le
courage de saborder cette carrière
solidement bâtie pour l'incertitude d'un
rêve d'une chimère qui échouera
peut-être et si entre temps vous avez
fondé une famille à qui en bien
il faudrait un sacré cran pour tenter
quand je parle de rap de projets je
pense pas forcément quelque chose de
plus platement alternatif au sens de
radicalement différent de ce que vous
envisagez vous de ce qu'on envisage
pour vous l'important c'est de savoir ce
que fait mon objectif là ce n'est pas de
vous convaincre vous persuader de tous
devenir enseignant mais juste de vous
pousse à vous interroger à quoi
voulez-vous heureux qu'est ce qui vous
motive
pourquoi vous lever le matin j'ai fait
le choix leur école parce que je voulais
combat fait des terminaisons et s'il
m'est insupportable c'est parce qu'avoir
confiance de mes privilèges me met la
pression on m'a tout donné pour que je
réussisse
j'ai le potentiel de réussir je dois
réussir et c'est quoi réussir c'est quoi
la réussite c'est quoi - ça le site
je crois en l'engagement je crois que si
chacun sait pourquoi elle se lève le
matin il donne le meilleur de lui même
c'est pourquoi je ne peux que vous
encourager à chercher ce qui fait sens
pour vous et moins de vous fermer des
portes
l'éventail des possibilités se révèle
encore plus large je dis regardez moi je
suis en train de faire un top talk jeu
pas sûr que vous mourriez invités si
j'avais continué tg était devenue
consultante vous avez cette chance vous
avez ce pouvoir d'investir votre énergie
et vos compétences au service de ce qui
compte pour vous saisissez cette chance
jouissait ce pouvoir ouvrez votre voix
c'est comme ça que vous réaliserez votre
potentiel et si jamais votre chemin vous
ramène au collège je serai ravi de vous
y croisez merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]